the human heart is still one of the
biggest mysteries in medicine and
Anatomy the main reason for our lack of
understanding is the complexity of the
heart structure and its phenotype
however modern technology is helping us
to understand this amazing organ at the
Barcelona supercomputing Center and in
close collaboration with medical doctors
and bio engineers we are developing a
large scale simulator of the human heart
called a Lea red the computational
cardiac model a computational
description of the heart requires
information at very different scales in
time and space from the ions inside the
cells or the muscular tissue that forms
the organ and up to the whole individual
because it is not practical to compute
all the scales the same level of detail
our cardiac model is based on the organ
scale at this level a heartbeat is
driven by an electrical impulse that
causes the muscular contraction which in
turn is responsible for the pumping
action for this reason we say that the
heart is a coupled physical system in
our simulator we can apply electric
impulses directly to any zones of the
heart just like a pacemaker would do
these initial impulses unleash a
generalized propagation of electricity
through the whole cardiac structure in a
coordinated way thanks to the optimized
organization of muscular fibres this
electrical flash makes the ventricles
contract during what is known as the
system to create the best possible
cardiac stimulator in terms of realism
and detail we rely on tourism data that
have not been available
the geometry and shape of the hearts are
measured to use in magnetic resonance
imaging with a resolution of up to 36
micrometers which allows us to construct
her matched with hundreds of thousands
of computational elements electricity
travels much faster along cardiac
muscular fibres than across them so a
correct anatomical description of their
arrangement is probably the most
important element in obtaining a
realistic electromechanical model of the
heart
cardiac fibres are specially organized
to allow the contraction of the heart
cavities in a coordinated stable and
efficient way until very recently the
only way to describe cardiac fiber
arrangements was with simplified models
based on histological sections of animal
hearts today we can achieve a much
better description of the fibers using a
technique called diffusion tensor
imaging using magnetic resonance to map
the diffusion of water molecules along
biological tissues in our cardiac
simulator we can use diffusion tensor
imaging information as well as
mathematical models allowing us to
validate theory with experiments and
improve our numerical methods alia the
software developed at the Barcelona
supercomputing Center has been designed
from scratch for an efficient use of
large parallel clusters producing
accurate simulation of a heart requires
considerable computing power that's why
we perform our simulations on BSC's
supercomputer Marin Ostrom where
calculations can be distributed among
10,000 processors working in a tightly
coordinated way these simulations will
help medical doctors to better
understand how our body works to
diagnose pathologies to plan operations
and treatments and to test and design
new drugs nowadays large-scale
simulations of the human body may seem
like science fiction but techniques like
magnetic resonance were also science
fiction only 50 years ago with the help
of information technology the future of
medicine is being
today
you